Drug addiction is a disease and it's a mental disease,
the leading explanations or hijacking and prior self medication.
Most people think of it as hijacking the innate reward and pain suppression
systems are involved in generating this kind of vulnerability.
So one way of looking at drug addiction is,
is hijacking the reward system that we have built into us to shape our own
behavior.
Another possibility is that it is the consequence of the history of selected
self medication with plant compounds.
There is genetic variation in susceptibility to addiction,
which means that it could be responding to selection in contemporary
populations.
Let's take a look at the innate reward systems to see how evolution may have set
us up to be vulnerable to hijacking are two kinds of rewards systems and there
are two types of pleasure sensations.
One rewards,
anticipation and the other one rewards satisfaction.
Yeah,
anticipation is rewarded by the dopamine urging pathways that control appetite,
epic editive behavior
satisfaction is rewarded by the opioid pathways that control consumptive
behaviors and suppress pain.
Okay.
Dopaminergic pathways are targeted by psycho stimulants like cocaine and
methamphetamine speed.
They counteract frustration,
depression,
and despair.
Opioid pathways are targeted by opium and heroin.
They counteract hunger,
thirst,
and pain.
Both systems are based on feed forward and negative feedback circuits of
homeostasis.
The topo been urgent.
Reward system is centered on the nucleus accumbens and it receives inputs from
the medial prefrontal cortex from the anterior singular cortex,
from the orbital frontal Cortex,
and from the hippocampus.
Yeah,
it is centered on transcription factor Delta Foss B that's expressed in the
ventral tegmental area of the nucleus accumbens in the in the nucleus accumbens
and the in part of the prefrontal cortex.
Okay.
Addictive drugs rewire this reward circuitry and enhance expression of Delta
Foss B and that produces a feeling of pleasure.
The opioid rewards system elicits the pleasure of satisfaction,
whether that's caused by food consumption or by pain relief.
Yeah.
The pituitary gland can produce neuropeptides called endorphins that act like
opioids inhibiting pain signals in producing a feeling of euphoria.
Yeah.
Endorphins can be released as part of the fight or flight response in
anticipation of possible pain.
How has the reward system hijacked?
Well,
opioids like morphine and heroin activate the receptors that mediate natural
endorphin signaling.
Cocaine inhibits stole from me and re uptake transports stimulating dopaminergic
rewards and nicotine binds to asset teal Coleen receptors,
the trigger,
the release of dopamine in the ventral tegmental and adrenaline and the
adrenaline Mandala.
Yeah,
alcohol enhances the binding of glutamate.
Triggering is an expression of Delta Foss B and the activity of nicotine urging
nicotinic acid [inaudible] Coleen receptors that triggers the release of
dopamine,
so you can see that many of these drugs are triggering receptors that result in
the release of dopamine.
Amphetamines have many effects including enhancing the expression of Delta Foss
B which is a central player.
They all set in motion events that lead to the sensation of pleasure,
the cessation of pain or both.
Another hypothesis for why drug addiction exists is that we have an evolutionary
history of self medicating with plant compounds.
Both primates and insects that are infected with pathogens consume plants
containing compounds that have curative effects.
The self medication hypothesis posits that humans have long been exposed by
plant compounds with curative properties,
have sought them out when infected and have evolved to reward system that
motivates them to seek out such planned compounds when if it went infected.
There was some preliminary evidence that suggest that tobacco smoke can reduce
worm burden,
but much more work is needed.
Humans very genetically in their susceptibility to addiction.
There are genotypes that are much more susceptible than others.
Addictive substances are sensed by the receptors and processed by the enzymes
that also deal with drugs.
Humans therefore very genetically and their susceptibility to drug addiction
just as they do when their ability to process drugs,
the heritability of susceptibility to addictive agencies.
Hi,
here's an example.
This is the heritability of susceptibility,
for example,
to hello synogen.
It's about 0.4 to sedatives.
It's about 0.55 and to cocaine it's about 0.7 so that means that there is a lot
of genetic variation out there in the population for susceptibility to teach
these sorts of drugs.
This mean that people are more susceptible to cocaine.
It means that there's more variation for susceptibility to cocaine addiction.
So to summarize,
drug addiction results from ingesting substances,
the trigger systems that evolve to shape adaptive behaviors through the reward
of pleasure and the suppression of pain.
Such exposure may be an evolutionary novelty or an experience with an
evolutionary history.
Addiction illustrates the principle that every adaptive system contains a
vulnerability that can permit the expression of a disease,
such vulnerabilities,
often very genetically among individuals.